oh hi
it's time for one of my favorite
segments dear drew
all right i put out a call to action for
people to send in
actual snail mail and much to our
surprise and delight
we got a ton of mail and i want to get
to our letters but first i'd love to
celebrate
our zip code of the day 33916
in fort myers florida
that's right it's also home to um our
local cbs affiliate
wink tv i don't know if you saw the show
earlier but
animals love it fort myers is home to
the only seashell museum in the world
and i know by the way i needed to see
that
and then it was also the winter vacation
spot of thomas edison
that's right the dude who invented the
light bulb
who knew he was a snowbird which i just
learned
means you don't like the cold so you go
warm for winter
send us some letters please we'd love to
open them on the show
as we are gonna do right now letter
number one hello
this is from autumn in waltonville
illinois oh hold on dear drew i wanted
to write you and introduce my incredibly
amazing mom
wendy um and the four of
the sorry mom of four and long time
essential worker of the u.s postal
service oh my gosh
this is so apropos um i have always
loved my mom so much and i thought that
you and i were sister spirits and she's
celebrating her 46th birthday this week
would you maybe give her some kind words
well
wendy i love what you do and
i thank you for delivering the mail
because you deliver
love every day and necessities so
thank you for everything you do go ah
go usps i love you
i am that guy who totally like stops at
every like person i'm like
yeah and they're like okay cool
um okay this is letter number two this
is from nico
in los angeles california oh my old
hometown
all right she writes growing up everyone
called me a drew look alike uh
nico you freaking me out
like is this a photoshop thing i mean
this is crazy
look at this we are the same person
okay raquel thank you so much
um that was nico thank you okay
look i'm sorting through the mail it's
not a perfect system um
okay this is from raquel
and she's from salem oregon oh i love
oregon
all right dear drew i love that you're
bringing the written word back
thank you um to you and your animals
um thank you for sharing the positivity
and
i happen to have a medical bill for
blood work
and it's been really hard times and i've
struggled to pay this
thank you for taking the time to read it
and thank you for all that you're doing
all right raquel i don't want you to
stress over this anymore
i want you to take care of yourself so
i'm going to pay your medical bill
if anyone out there has a bill needs
advice because i live to give advice
look we're all better advisors to others
than ourselves and i'm all about
self-improvement so
god dear drew like i love dear abby so
much
so you know any kind of stuff like that
that harkens back to a tradition
i've always been a fan of if you want to
tell me a joke
send me a fun family photo i'm game
bail me any thoughts questions requests
heartfelt funny story all right i can't
wait
to read more of your letters on this
show and thank you to my dear drew pen
pals autumn
nico and raquel all right i am going to
be
putting these oh god stamps you have no
idea
like how much i love stamps all right
i'm putting stamps on i'm gonna mail
these
in the mailbox right now this is how
much i love mail
i have a mailbox all right that should
kind of show you
where i'm at with this thing here we go
it's been sent we'll be right back